hey what's up youtube hope you're having
a great day so i wanted to take a short
amount of time to talk about elden ring
and sort of the backlash the game is
getting from certain gamers and
streamers who are having a tough time
progressing and feel discouraged to play
the game at all i completely understand
how you feel because i remember when i
first started playing souls games myself
i actually started with dark souls 3 and
really struggled with it initially until
i started to understand more about how
the game worked i got absolutely
destroyed by the first boss gundyr
dozens of times before i finally beat
him and i can tell you i wasn't happy
after i beat him i was a bit discouraged
but over time i started to learn more
things about the game that made my time
playing it easier and increased my
enjoyment of the game immensely so much
so that i can say that the souls games
meaning dark souls 1 through 3
bloodborne and skiro are some of my
favorite games of all time even though i
didn't play the games in order of when
they first launched so the big issue
i've been seeing is that the first main
boss you're going to come across market
is too difficult the advanced move and
range of damage that margate can do
against you as a player is hard however
i believe that margate is intentionally
difficult in hopes that players will go
and discover other areas and eventually
come back to market when they're
stronger because that's the beauty of
elden ring you don't have to follow the
path all the way up to the castle to
fight margaret you can go anywhere your
heart and sense of discovery desires for
some people this may be sort of
overwhelming because of what they're
used to when it comes to playing a video
game most video games tell you exactly
where to go and tell you exactly what to
do eldon ring will not hold your hand
and that is meant to be a good thing the
developers know that you the player are
smart enough and capable enough to deal
with the challenges that the game gives
you and this is still pretty different
from the usual souls game experience
which has you make your way through a
generally linear level until you come
across a boss and the only way to
progress through the rest of the game is
for you to beat that boss so you'll just
fight the boss over and over again until
you beat it and then you can progress in
eldon ring you can absolutely do that
you can bash your head into the wall
fighting the boss again and again and
you will eventually beat it and you will
probably walk out of that fight more
frustrated than happy which is not the
experience the developers want you to
have they understand that past souls
games were really uninviting to most
gamers since there is no difficulty
setting there is no easy mode even in
elden ring everyone who plays the game
is going up against the same challenges
as you in the exact same ways but it's
up to you as the player to decide how
you want to handle those challenges in
your own special way
depending on your class your weapon the
skill arts that you use the spells that
you can obtain almost anything and that
has been the case with all the past
games as well but the developers this
time around with elden ring made it more
accessible than ever to feel progression
within the game you do not have to
follow the path put in front of you
because they do put a path in front of
you literally and on your map to walk
all the way up to the castle and fight
margaret right off the rip but you do
not have to follow this path there is no
linear pathway to progression you can go
in any direction you want and nothing is
going to stop you and this is a far
stretch from the usual formula of
bashing your head against a wall until
you finally overcome the challenge they
still give you that option like i said
and if you're into that sort of thing
but the decisions you can make on how to
handle the challenges put in front of
you
are literally endless how i've been
playing elden ring is i just go wherever
i want i explore the areas that are
presented to me and i at least try to
face the challenges in whatever area i'm
in if i feel like i'm not strong enough
to beat a boss or can't get past a
certain area then i just go somewhere
else and explore even more and by doing
this i come across enemies that aren't
going to stop my progression i defeat
them get better at the mechanics and the
intricacies of the game i level up and
get stronger and i feel good about doing
it yeah i felt a bit discouraged after
getting absolutely destroyed by marga at
first and i'm a veteran souls player but
what i did was i just ventured off and
got lost in this amazing world for hours
and hours on end for me to just remember
oh yeah i still need to go beat margaret
but by that point i had gotten so much
stronger that market wasn't that big of
a challenge so that's what i mean
by margaret being intentionally
difficult it isn't meant to completely
discourage you it's meant to tell you to
go out and get stronger go practice
improve learn explore and then you will
eventually be ready to face that
challenge it is totally ok to not
immediately overcome a challenge the
first time you come across it that's the
whole point of all of these games is to
overcome almost impossible
odds because i promise you you can
absolutely beat this game you can beat
any boss that boss you're struggling
with isn't that hard when you learn its
moveset or use a certain spell or a
weapon or an exploit or a certain level
up but you won't learn those things
unless you properly expose yourself to
the options that are presented to you
and yes absolutely they are presented to
you just not in the normal fashion of
putting a giant icon over the top of it
and telling you to walk and click here
again the game will not hold your hand
and that isn't meant to discourage you
it's meant to help you and there is
nothing i want more
than for more players to play elden ring
i want them to have as good of an
experience as i'm currently having but
it definitely definitely
doesn't have to be in the exact same way
i'm doing it but if you can just go off
and look at this world from a different
perspective look at all the love and
care that is put into this game that we
just don't see very much in most games
that release nowadays and i believe you
will have that good experience and
appreciation for what we have been given
with elden ring it's not perfect because
nothing can be perfect but there is love
attention and care to every single thing
and i promise you that the developers
did not want to discourage anybody from
playing their game that just wouldn't be
smart for them in general you can beat
eldon ring
absolutely
if you have any questions or need help
with anything with elden ring leave a
comment or check out my twitch channel
where i'll be streaming the game every
single day thanks for watching the video
leave a like and subscribe if you feel
like it see you in the next video gamers